reg Halloween plans this time as we all
know Halloween is all about the little
kids so we'll be trick-or-treating and
if you're going to ask well I'd be
dressing up no no no no I will have a
mask on probably just a little scary
mask to kind of be festive a little bit
but the full-on come on
once you turn 15 yeah can't dress up
anymore right what teen is the cutoff
have you gone to a Halloween party last
time you went to a Halloween party and
dressed up oh oh probably when I played
we had a team Halloween party every year
so that's probably the last time I've
gone to a party where everyone was
dressed up and who'd you dress up as
every year I was the greatest
Entertainer of all time should I break
him out right now mix it up and go as
Prancer no no I went like I was 1 year I
was 5 year old ABC I want you back
Michael and then I was the destiny
Jackson to her Michael and then
obviously I was off-the-wall Michael and
then another year I was thriller Michael
and then I became bad Michael and then
remember the time do you remember the
time oh yes
you could be a whole bunch of Michael
Jackson's Reggie's got the call it'll be
the Lakers and the Blazers that'll be a
doubleheader on TNT hey a few things
talk about here when do we get concerned
about the Cavaliers here after the new
year but I am NOT concerned whatsoever
just like I'm not concerned with teams
getting off to great starts here in
October everyone is a feeling out
process there's only one team with that
cohesion and that's the Golden State
Warriors the defending champs everyone
else is trying to figure it out and
trying to get to know one another
there's a lot of new
moving parts with coach Liu and the
Cleveland Cavaliers and if this
continues after January 1st and into the
all-star break that's when you need to
be concerned their defense is terrible
reg I don't know even if everybody's
healthy if that defense is going to be
any good yes but one thing that is
correctable and quickly can be your
defense when you've got LeBron James in
here submit this claim god-awful right
now on both ends of the floor yeah but
they have the pieces to become a better
defensive team and let's not forget
their second-best player is probably out
until mid-january maybe February in
Isiah Thomas so they don't have their
full roster yet so that's why I'm not
concerned as long as LeBron stays
healthy and engaged that's the big word
he has to stay engaged it can be
frustrated with this new process with
all these new players if he's still
engaged and healthy it's the East -
let's not forget it's the East it's not
the West speaking of the process what do
you think of the 76ers so far
love it they're gonna take their lumps
their ups and downs you saw the
game-winner that Houston had against
them at home they're gonna win some and
lose some but I like the young talent
that they're developing there I think
once MB could be cleared to play every
game and not every other game and Ben
Simmons again we talked about this last
week he'll win Rookie of the Year even
though he's not really technically in my
opinion at rookie because he's been in
the system now this would be his second
year Ben Simmons is what we thought he
would be he is a very poor man's version
of LeBron James being able to do
everything being that point forward and
he played well last night and and you
know these teams are going to do what I
said you should do is make him shoot a
jumper
he made the jumpers last night but
that's probably going to be the way you
know team's approach him and probably
Lonzo ball you got Lakers at the Blazer
a Blazers coming up what do you expect
in that matchup well obviously you know
the highlights gonna be long so going
against Damian Lillard and/or CJ
McCollum Portland has got off to a rough
start as well last night at home
Toronto it was a 20-point thrashing by
the Raptors over the Blazers and this is
a team that on paper has talent you know
we mentioned the two cards but you
Seffner kitc the guy the big guy in the
middle to me is one of the unsung big
men in this game and when healthy you
can play with his back to the basket he
can face you up and is a terrific passer
so Terry Stotts has the talent to be a
playoff team maybe an eighth seed in the
Western Conference but again it's one of
those teams trying to find themselves
early on in the season and I like to
comment coming out of Lonzo ball
don't try to praise us and kill me now
and then try to praise me later on when
we figured it out you know so like we
knew this is going to happen with the
Lakers a young team with a lot of young
talent and a young coach still in coach
Walton so they're gonna take their lumps
so it's one of those games where it's a
lot of young starred talent on the floor
but it's a it's a pickup game really I
mean this is a game as the Lakers can
win on the road what about what you've
seen with the Knicks it seems like Chris
Thompson angus is enjoying Carmelo
Anthony being in Oklahoma City why are
you trying to start controversy if I
said this hey it seems like kristaps
porzingis certainly is enjoying himself
with the Knicks should I stop there and
then you wouldn't have you wouldn't have
brought in Carmelo and then I would say
well then I would say yes because the
office is being ran directly through him
he's the go-to guy we wouldn't even have
to mention Melo but yes there's more
spacing out there and Tim Hardaway jr. I
thought was a great pick up for them a
good addition to play alongside
porzingis so yes they've seemed to have
figured it out that was a big win on the
road in Cleveland so we mentioned the
struggles of the Cavaliers but uh yeah
maybe he's starting to figure this out a
little bit but it's only gonna get
tougher for porzingis because when you
are the man and the go-to man and team
start to double and triple teams they
haven't even started to triple team yet
because
respect to nix that way but they will
once they get more talent I want to see
what happens when they start to double
and triple-teamed him yeah I think he's
averaging less than one assists per game
so I think it's point eight that's far
Melo dominated him in that category red
[Laughter]
is a great talent freakish athlete can
run the floor can finish in traffic can
block shots but one thing he needs to
improve on is finding his teammate and
that won't come in time because right
now he's had single coverage throughout
his NBA career but Reggie he's got a
fine teammates first then to find those
team I agree so once he finds some
teammates then he can find his teammates
hey hey I could throw you the basketball
if you miss it why is that I mean well
that's why I didn't want to pass because
I realized that I could throw it to you
but I like the option of me did you ever
feel that way how many times did you do
that where you thought I could throw it
to Mark Jackson or you know Rik Smits
but I I'm a better shooter than no no
those guys I would definitely throw two
I'll be like the best option is for this
ball this rally little little orange
ball to stay in my hands you wouldn't
throw it to the Davis
you wouldn't thrown it to the Davis no
no you definitely do it to them I
definitely thrown it - hey would work
then - Derrick McKey you purposely did
not throw it to him you just didn't love
their shot that's there's nothing wrong
with that like if I played pickup with
the dance I'm not throwing the ball to
fritzy or Paulie smart move and I love
them no I'm not throwing it to them
they're terrible they're terrible but
McLovin and Seaton would get the ball so
now it's your turn I respect I respect
all my Indiana
teammates throughout the years but if
there was a player I I would not throw
the basketball - I would or - all over
land would make the right play I would
make the right play I would make the
right play are you rooting against the
Dodgers tonight I'm not rooting against
them but today I could not remember our
World Series that's been this riveting
because we finally have options usually
it's a 2 to 1 1 2 0 3 2 2 game I mean
you don't know what's going crazy inning
to inning so I'm not rooting against
them but go angels that's all I'm gonna
say go angels
Haywood workman you wouldn't throw it -
right
[Laughter]
what's the situation is a game on the
line yeah game on the line like if I'm
coming out if I'm coming off a double
team you're double-teamed and his man
comes off he's he's wide open at the top
of the key I love you NBA referee I
really do how about - Richardson well
who's our relationship goes back to UCLA
so I'm definitely throwing the ball to
poo yeah but he couldn't shoot he could
to the point guard every five times to
make him think that you're thinking of
them did did anybody didn't Luke Walton
bring up your shot and as a reference to
Lanza ball he did because everyone is
concerned about why those balls shot and
how an unorthodox it is and
he was like we'll look at Reggie you
know no one is telling him to change his
shot he's one of the greatest shooters
of all time Thank You Luke I did
appreciate the rods up but I wouldn't
change it either did you try him
straight how did they try to make you
change your shot not change they tried
to tweak you know Tiger was going
through those stages of him tweaking his
swing every what three or four years
yeah they tried to tweak it but uh I
like the ball go in all the time and
that was it wait are you a farmer in his
down are you the Tiger Woods of shooters
is that what you just called yourself
I never tweet my and I never tweet oh
you know I treat his Gosling I never
tweet now I would emulate certain shots
coming off screens like some of the guys
I followed like I comment off to my left
I emulated Larry Bird's high arching
fadeaway three so I tried to shoot it
like him come up to my right I tried to
emulate Dale Ellis who shot the ball
right in front of his forehead because
that's a quicker shot coming off to your
right so I shot at different ways from
different shooters that I admired and
how quickly they got the basketball off
but I never tweaked personally my own
shot he's a Reggie Miller Hall of Famer
NBA on TNT analyst he's got Blazers
Lakers 10:30 Eastern on TNT first game
of a doubleheader tip-off at 8:00
Eastern between the Warriors and the
Spurs reg as always safe travels great
to talk to you and we'll talk to you
next week
Peter you were the best Nikola win win
win I could win
McLovin you can get Lululemon here in
the city I guess we'll have to look at
Reggie schedule to see what he's
available you could probably wear this
tomorrow but Reggie you warned yoga
pants haven't you in California I
thought that was a we'll leave that to
the imagination thanks reg that's Reggie
Miller for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]